well many parents are opting to place
their kids in charter schools for a
variety of reasons so today we're taking
a look at how the district's charter
schools perform do they meet certain
benchmarks the results of a brand new
study are in madison kimbrough joins us
now live from sahara and jones with
those numbers madison
we're currently here at odyssey charter
just one of the district charter schools
here across the valley now on ccsd's
evaluation report this particular school
got three to four stars consistently
from 2018 into now
odyssey charter has met the district's
academic financial and organizational
standards however other charter schools
on the list such as a hundred academy
school of engineering and technology in
north las vegas have not met any of the
standards for the past five years
rainbow dreams and the delta academy had
very low ratings in the one to two star
range as well in the report ccsd is
working closely with these schools to
assist in improving all areas of the
charter school performance framework i
spoke to parents at these lower start
schools who share with me what these
ratings mean to them to me the school is
amazing like meeting the standards i
don't know but for my chat my two kids
that go here they go above and beyond to
make them meet the standards these
teachers here are more active in
the kids like they're more they're more
into you know individual as for those
other schools that scored high on the
list explore knowledge academy did very
well meeting almost all of their
standards within the past five years
the school district sponsors several
charter schools across the valley and
when we reached out to the district we
were told the school board meeting
that's happening tomorrow is going to be
your best chance to get more information
on this topic reporting live near
saharan jones madison kimbrough live
local now